[Music]
hello there and welcome to Playstation
grenade
over the last month I've been completely
addicted to the remaster of Call of
Duty's modern warfare 2 and now the game
has released on PC and Xbox now is a
great time to go over all the Easter
eggs all the secrets and the weird and
wonderful things you can unlock in this
beautiful game he is 21 things I found
please use the comments below if I miss
anything
I'll heart your comment to get you
noticed anyway you ready let's do this
we are starting with a returning Easter
egg from the original modern warfare 2
back in 2009 which has been updated for
this remaster we're in Brazil just after
the white vehicle comes in out of
nowhere don't move forward instead go to
the far right corner to find a hidden
back passage which leads to this shrine
as you'd expect a sheriff teddy is here
as that's the calling card of Call of
Duty games but it's the poster that
we're interested in this band image is
actually staff from the game's remaster
team at B Knox
I looked up the whole squad and found
that wow there is a lot of people
working on this remaster we can see the
leading lady from the poster here I only
found this due to her hair color I'll
let you find the other members in this
group I've been promised though they are
here somewhere around the rest of the
level it's possible to spot that poster
again and again and photos of the
developers and their children when you
reach the football pitch go into this
door here to find a line of mug shots of
those brilliant people who brought this
remaster to life you gorgeous buggers
whilst in Brazil and running through the
market take a moment to find this TV
screen as inside it hides another
returning Easter egg a teddy hidden
inside the telly you'll likely find this
TV already shot to pieces but it's
possible to find it in perfect condition
if you quick enough but it won't stay
that way for very long a great addition
to the modern warfare 2 remaster is the
ability to inspect our own weapons on
ps4 that's down on the d-pad but have
you tried to do this on a mission
without a weapon it doesn't work on all
levels but during the Hornets
to where roach is running to Bob the
helicopter take a moment to inspect your
weapon Roach will have a quick game of
rock-paper-scissors with himself
complete with winning actions in a
mission with a 30-second countdown I had
to find an epic way to use this emote so
check it out
nope I do not have anything better to do
with my time let's go back to the first
mission in the game well it's more of a
training exercise really here we can
take part in three Easter eggs the first
is the one which blew our mind 11 years
ago it's possible to shoot our
commanding officer general Shepherd if
you don't know why that's important to
please turn this video off right now
have they gone as you and I know
Shepherd is revealed to be the real bad
guy after doing the unthinkable to ghost
I'm not crying
you're crying well in the first mission
of the game it's possible to take out
Shepherd for a trophy or achievement
Call of Duty love these little time
paradox trophies and there's another one
coming up very soon back when the
original Modern Warfare series released
Robert bowling was the creative
strategist and when he was interviewed
about his experience with the game and
an insane kill streak he racked up he
recalled it as the stealth clown as he
hid behind a sign shaped like a clown at
a fun fair as I call not to this map
three clowns could be found in the
training level which gives us yet
another trophy achievement in the
barracks you'll need to find the 50 Cal
sniper and it only has three bullets
inside you've got to make these shots
count your job is to find and eliminate
those three clowns if you need help on
this here's where they're all at
[Music]
and yet another easter egg in the first
mission is actually a cameo from two
celebrities you may already know many of
the NPCs can be walked up to and listen
to stick around long enough and you'll
hear this I don't think those guys from
Delta know I'm pretty sure some of them
or Delta except for maybe that deal with
the freaky mask I remember that guy he
was totally no regulation man oh you
think I better do with the more so let's
break that down first the actors are
Will Arnett the voice of Bojack horseman
and the other is $0.50 or two give him
his boring everyday name Curtis Jackson
they are actually talking about soap and
ghosts and their individual looks which
completely break military dress code I
mean a mohawk maybe it's an sas thing in
fact there's another thing to notice
right here check out the dog tags of
this character it's actually a quote
from Aristotle we make war that we may
live in peace who doesn't love an OG
oxymoron on a piece of tin these
proverbs are regularly seen in the game
after we die and I die a lot so I've
seen many of these well if we go to the
snowy mission cliffhanger in which we
meet up with soap and go through a
snowstorm at the start of the mission
deliberately fall to your death from
this height for a new proverb to pop up
on screen designed to make you feel
worthless if you fall I'll be there by
the famous philosopher the flaw
ouch do this again and you'll be
compared to the children's nursery rhyme
Humpty Dumpty who also was famous for
having a great fault but let's turn this
frown upside down because we aren't
completely useless after scaling the icy
Falls and soap tells us to take out
these evil henchmen from distance ignore
him and go up for a special one-off
elimination using those ice pickaxes
check this out
brutal come on soap you're impressed I
know he's impressed you totally
impressed
moving on to that mission you know the
one know Russian well I'm gonna stay
away from the controversy and stick to a
handful of great Easter eggs
the best is another paradox and if you
haven't played modern warfare 3
I suggest you skip forward a little if
you have played modern warfare 3 you'll
know all about Yuri a teammate who
fights alongside us only to be revealed
as Makarovs best friend as soap dies in
front of our eyes
turns out Yuri was there the day price
was all Gilad up and shot Zack I eV
but he survived that assassination
attempt little did we know both Makarov
and Yuri were in the car he ran to that
day and soon after Makarov rose to power
and Yuri watched his ideologies collapse
and decided to switch sides just before
the no Russian mission Makarov found out
about Yuri's change of heart and shot
his friend Yuri tried to fight back by
crawling into the elevator and pursuing
Makarov only to pass out in the airport
from blood loss this brings us
up-to-date as yuri is now an easter egg
in modern warfare 2 remastered when
playing through the mission double back
down the escalators after you get to
this fall and sunglasses stunt if you're
quick enough you'll see Yuri gun drawn
in pursuit he'll collapse in front of
your eyes a great easter egg I'm sure
you'll agree but here's where it gets
weird firstly shooting Yuri results in a
mission failure as he is actually an
ally at this point and also if we throw
a stun grenade at Yuri his character
will reset and he'll stand up reloading
his weapon I had fun with Yuri for many
hours pushing him into the metal
detector before Makarov came back and
killed us both again
[Music]
overall one of the best Easter eggs I've
seen that merged the law into something
special to really reward true fans of
the series absolutely mind-blowing GG
devs there are more things to notice at
the airport such as the the luggage if
you shoot it close and breakables fly
everywhere similarly if you shoot the
vending machines they will completely
drop their loads everywhere but these
are details not Easter eggs so let's get
back to Easter eggs get your butts in
the elevator at the end of the mission
and you'll see IW engraved in the
operation panel these are the initials
of the original developing studio
Infinity Ward scratched into history
also while you here in the airport
you'll see a version of Burger King
complete with its own version of the
whopper but my favorite Easter Egg in
this little hallway is the original
artwork of the game which can be found
on a countertop in this wine and whiskey
store it looks like Captain Price was
originally planned to be on the front
cover looking like this if we interact
with this by shooting it the back of the
cover is identical to the one which was
released in real life yet another great
touch at this point you may have noticed
that some of my gameplay is a little
strange
due to the collectables in the game
which unlock weird and wonderful extras
for example there's an unlockable
ability for grenades to spawn more
grenades another mod called badiya makes
enemies morph into tires when they are
killed this is in reference to the tire
company Goodyear but my personal
favorite is the pineapple mode in which
every single enemy has a pineapple on
their head while allies keep their usual
faces this is particularly gutting as it
shows the exact moment Shepard becomes
the enemy see it for yourself
that's one less Lucifer
this is making me dislike pineapples are
Missy a ghost in fact while we're here
let's look at the easter eggs in loose
ends firstly did you ever notice the
newspaper clipping on the table it
references an attack by Makarov in the
City of London over in Piccadilly this
is doubly brilliant as that mission
actually does take place in the reboot
of Call of Duty from last year 2019 a
brilliant touch of continuity between
two timelines oh and if you're wondering
who writes these articles the newspaper
is the Infinity Ward Times brilliant and
you can find yet another movie poster
downstairs in the weapon stronghold
it's the devs again you find them here's
the picture I totally watch that film by
the way Russian Terminator come me in
probably their most well-known Easter
Egg here is the very strange one which
gets stranger than more you think about
it after breaching and entering a room
upstairs in the cabin you'll discover
something in the bathtub it's a it's a
doll for adults let's just call it that
in a house full of Russian men it needs
something like this I suppose also note
that the hand prints on the dolls chest
and their stains on the dolls you know
what let's let's not do this moving on
please
when the Russians land on US soil the
mission is called Wolverines and this is
a direct reference to the movie Red Dawn
in fact there's a trophy name that to a
film where the USSR invaded USA on this
mission you can also find the Burger
King restaurant we talked about and
there's a Taco Bell - damn I'm hungry
right now here's one I can't figure out
if you'd help me that would be much
appreciated in the first part of the
mission when you're funneled down the
back alleys there is a tea party between
a clown and the space alien does this
have a reason for being here is this an
easter egg or just a random item let me
know your thoughts please I'll be
looking in the comments
well we're speaking about oddities now
so let's carry on with that a strange
updated element in the game is here in
the original modern warfare 2 it was
possible to find an Afghan military
fighter completely unbothered by the
battle he should be fighting in and just
munching down on chocolate instead well
fast-forward 11 years and in the
remaster the chocolate eater is back but
this
time he's in the u.s. ranks that
chocolate must be damn tasty my final
Easter egg is during the final march
towards the White House in the bunker
section it's possible to locate this
room look behind the boxes to discover
yet another bear but it's what it's
holding that's important here a golden
Desert Eagle this is a really strong
weapon which one shots most enemies
kinda like the golden gun on the n64
version of Goldeneye so I thought like
many others this must be a reference to
the man with the Golden Gun
Birds Eye played the final mission and
Shepard reveals his callsign and guess
what it is golden eagle and our final
battle takes place in the desert so
maybe this golden desert eagle was
foreshadowing all along or am i reaching
here thanks Teddy anyway I'll end this
video with the additional dialogue you
can unlock before taking out shepard but
also let's make sure we take down that
big pineapple head and finish this saga
in the right way I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time you know what
they say about revenge you better be
ready to dig two graves go ahead and it
it won't change anything
I knew you couldn't do it oh you're a
good warrior but you can never take that
extra step to do what was absolutely
necessary
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you